let's go to our next caller from the 601
area code caller from 601 hello
introduce yourself and you can jump
right into your question hi there David
can you hear me we can hear you yeah go
ahead
this is Bryson from down in Mississippi
I got a question for you uh how soon do
you think we'll see the progressives and
moreover the Democrats finally turned
their attention back down south and win
what I see is the very winnable fight
down here
I mean how there's a many bastions of
what I consider all the liberal thought
all around here and uh I guess are more
populated cities we have several
colleges and as closer you get down to
New Orleans it gets you know quite
progressive in my opinion yeah some
cities there are I mean just a big
picture we know about the rural southern
divide so even in the south there are
lots of cities in red states where the
city will either be like a 50/50
Democratic Republican voting City or
even sometimes a blue City but it's the
sort of total state populations that
make statewide races winnable but what's
important about that is that there may
be opportunities in the midterms if
people actually get out and vote which I
sound like you're going to but I don't
know if everybody's going to to take
some congressional districts back from
Republicans and maybe even some
senatorial some Senate seats I
completely agree with you ignoring the
South if that's what Democrats plan to
do is a horrible idea
but I think it's also important to be
realistic and with limited sums of money
you want to target southern races that
you have a shot in versus the ones where
it's basically just like throwing money
out the window absolutely but I feel
like just this complete blind I turned
is uh not doing very good service yeah
but I don't know I mean do you are you
arguing that Democrats have turned a
total blind eye to the south I don't
think they have I think it's just
extremely selective now you might be
right about that yeah all right well
thank you for the call I I agree with
you Democrats have got to deal with the
south there are opportunities there big
big opportunities